belote rebelote et dix de der ça ne me
font pas le coeur moi qui ne suis pas un
spécialiste de belote coinchée par
contre lui michel perron a suivi avec
beaucoup d'attention le premier
championnat de france de belote qui se
tenait à la rochelle une belle bataille
ils étaient près de 800 samedi et
dimanche à s'affronter au premier
championnat de france de belote à la
rochelle une compétition qui fait suite
à la création la semaine dernière d'une
fédération nationale les organisateurs
devaient avoir présent à l'esprit la
fameuse partie de cartes de marcel
pagnol
car ce qu'il redoutait le plus c'était
les tricheurs pas moins de 100
commissaire était à l'affût de toute
contestation ou geste suspect un
pansement ne pourrait-il pas servir à
dissimuler des cartes et ce joueur
enrhumé n'est-il pas en réalité en train
de se doper un ordinateur a même été
mobilisés pour effectuer le comptage des
points mais aussi pour établir des
fiches sur les concurrents douteux la
compétition s'est terminée dimanche à 4
heures du matin alors bien sûr la
passion du jeu plus la fatigue parfois
on s'énerve chez moi
être réglo
oh oui au nouveau salut jours